- Oh ... My God!
(heavy rock music)
(laughing)
It hurts! It hurts!
- Today, we're going
vertical with pole dancing.
- I have never done pole dancing before.
- Neither have I.
- I've been on a limo bus
that had a pole before,
but this is my first pole dancing class.
- They put us in these little booty shorts
and I'm kind of feeling myself right now.
- Learning pole dancing as a couple,
it's empowering, it builds confidence,
and you also lose weight, you tone up,
you build muscle.
- I feel like if there's
no major injuries today,
that it will be a success.
- So, we're going to start
chest out, booty out.
Step, drag.
I want to see you looking at yourself
in the mirror like,
"Yeah, you sexy bitch."
In the mirror.
- You sexy bitch.
- There you go!
So, the first move that we are going
to learn today, is the Fireman Spin.
You're going to take it down
to the balls of your feet.
(cheering)
- Booty!
(oooing)
- That's mine.
- Booty, booty, booty!
- The next move that we are going to learn
is the Cradle Spin.
(cheering)
Swing that left leg in,
knees to chest here.
(cheering)
There you go!
That was better.
- We're, like, the best dance crew ever.
- Our last move is going to be,
the Cross Knee Release.
(dramatic music)
- Oh! Every man in the
room just went, "Oh!"
- I know, yeah!
- [Stephanie] I somehow feel
this is a little too advanced.
- Look at that.
- Oh my God, I can't stay here.
- Some of us don't have
the thigh meat required.
There's such a separation.
Grab that foot?
- Yes.
- Are you out of your mind?
Testicles!
- It's okay!
- There you go! Yeah!
- All right, and we're done.
(laughing)
- Now, imagine if you
had testicles in there.
(cheering)
- Teamwork makes the dream work!
- Riding up my butt.
(sensual pop music)
(cheering)
(clapping)
(awwing)
- Yes, look at that.
Where's my ones?
I need my ones!
(laughing and clapping)
- Today, I soared through the air
like a graceful canary.
- My crotch burns.
- I liked putting my legs out like, this.
- It's a full workout.
A lot of upper body.
- A lot of strength.
- A lot of core strength.
- I stress tested both
of my testicles today.
- Doing it as a couple was a lot of fun.
Getting to perform for
each other, as well.
- I'm sorry, Mom.
- When will we ever be in a video
that we can show our parents?
Is my question.
(hard rock music)